he's been red hot as a play ban Sedin couldn't
hang on shks will keep it alive long drive there
and a kick save by gorv awful lot there sent into
the zone right around Kyle burrow hurdle with a
backand as to get free here's Johansson turning
and looking shoots save by Blackwood sharks
aggressive on the PK had got a piece of that now
Johansson down to the mix swings it across shot GL
saved by Blackwood and that's what he did back on
October 14 you want to take a look at this replay
tell us what the pass was glub side CL side you
think that got a little ahead of Colton perhaps
the pass was a bit ahead of him and he just
couldn't quite get the mustard on major penalty
to Jacob McDonald add it to the point mckin swings
it for moik forand shoots in a save by McKenzie
Blackwood and again back in October at the sharte
it's just crazy how he can get that glove over so
fast it really is and mo wasn't just in that sweet
spot he needs to get in a sweet spot I agree with
that too into the [__] [Applause] score B to
Chin that might have been a double deflector off
of Bron it but certainly thein they have the one-
nothing lead here in Period number one deflected
inch to the like far post what do you think of
the pass from Jonathan Drew in that was a big
part of the play great pass he they thought he was
going to shoot it but it was deflected by nushin
all alone right there never got to Blackwood
Tes Sears it back from mckinon cross eyes pass
it's Shin bubbled it just a little bit but he's
so strong on that puck look at him go t back to
mckinon will he shoot this time no gleed score
M ran the perfect reera at the top of the crease
it's a power power play goal and the ABS have
taken a two nothing lead for ranid in his 15th
of the season and yet another assist for Nathan
McKinnon yep and he you can see he just gets it
off his stick there and just a beautiful pass by
McKennon and it gets it just over the glove just
over the glove and that extends mckennon's point
streak to 45 points this year and he can he can
replay so well don't you AG yes defensive players
especially Devonte Kim Reed plays so well ABS had
it on their stick couldn't get it out fired off
hurdle turns and fires it a save by goria I see
over there writing things down furiously I am I
mean I'm getting smarter up here thanks Hunter
I appreciate you're welcome set up the boards by
Byam here's Jonathan drwan got cut off in front
of the penalty boxes gets it for Colton Colton
collects finds wood he'll race it and shoot and
scores miles W short side rips it off the post
ah in and the ABS have taken a 3 nothing lead
for wood that's his sixth of the season the ABS
collected that puck bought hard for it smoking it
past the ear of McKenzie Blackwood gets the pass
and he goes like cross bar and over to the post
as you can see here oh it was actually the corner
it cornered in WoW who picks up his second helper
of the game that's two primary assists for number
27 Big durman Bangs it ahead watch out here comes
an opportunity olon Sav by Blackwood olon had a
break opportunity you know you look at the talent
it takes to go pull that puck behind you through
your legs Olsen's a fourth line center for the
ass folks but just gr fights through a kick rley
tried to get a piece of him there's zling to bang
it into the legs of McKinnon he'll walk in Far
Side shot saved by Blackwood he robs Ranon in yet
again F Center doesn't mean you don't have Wicked
talent and there's that sweet little backhand
pass Tes on timer that's missing the that
couldn't get the redirect M shushin out
musling on the far side Tes flops it
but it's gloved down by th couldn't
get it out of the Zone here's mckinon
down the slot he'll shoot off the post
rebound it will go to McKennon it ricocheted off
the post it hit Blackwood in the Rope roast and
deflects to the back of the Nets he has lucky
goal number 13 and he comes in shoots off the
post and it gets jammed in by the goalie and
that's what I don't call picking up the trash
like they're not picking up the trash at all
like he's right there just standing there 33
just standing there seeing oh yeah hey Hein
sends it in front and that one's off the side
of the net just outside the post great save
by giorgia especially in that butterfly yeah
looks like he got a little piece with his
right Pat long drive there deflected and
scored it was a long shot redirected down
to the ice in between the circles and then
skipped pass goria and the sharks are on
the board it's a 4-1 game a power play
goal the glove comes off right there the glove
comes off as edin watch this deflection in the
slot off not like can do there as a goalie like
when it's you're getting screened it's deflected
by the screener you can't do a lot I played
goalie in my practice on Wednesday actually
and and ice time starting to get rewarded with
some serious Point production and you look with
Logan o Conor that's set down deep in a redirect
by cogliano just missed long reot the flex sa go
Ryan Johansson cleans up on the near side into a
wide open goal out the ABS have the 5-1 leading
for Johansson he finally gets the double digits
with his 10th of the year in the ABS that blown It
Wide Open but he still works he keeps going he's
so critical for this team when it comes to being
a dominant second line Center as we go towards the
playoffs it's Ling and gets healthy we right here
just Johnny on the spot nice little shot by Caleb
Jones and Johansson says thank you for his 10th of
the Season that might be the quietest 10 goals
in the National hockey league but when he gets
rolling the talenter Ryan Johansson is ridiculous
white pad has gotten a work out there's a left
pad and sent ahead McKinnon's got to break he'll
race him down the SL shoots it a save by Blackwood
batted up high to the top of the circles back to
McKinnon McKinnon's going to go off McKinnon on
the Breakaway not stopped very often but that time
Blackwood you get to see them hit it's really cool
yeah it scared you a few times but it scares me
sometimes when I'm not paying attention guys oh
absolutely what timer save goria rebound save
store so hurdle will collect his second of the
contest on the power play that puck went right to
his backand he was able to lift it after a couple
of excellent kick Saves by Alexander gorgia and
they just put shot fors in a big hammer of a shot
there so you're looking at two rebounds that's
where it's tough for gorm there's the first shot
here comes the second oh they just got unlucky on
that bu bym had it on his stick trying to clear
the rebound not fair things are happening fast and
hurdle just gets lucky I clocked you at 1.9 that's
how he was he must have had one of those fast
uh what do you call Fr oh what a save by goria
terrific glove save on zland goalie he works
really hard just due to his size and his style
comes across gets that right in the glove see the
splits pushing that away and he's had to make some
great saves here in the last 5 minutes his team
kind of hang hanging him out to dry as the ABS are
struggling to stay focused knocked Away by barov
the shark net is empty as they Trail five to2 here
with five minutes to go Jared Bard did the same
thing last night at Winnipeg yeah credit to David
Quinn too just letting his team score Nathan m
h it from the red line Force the turnover fires
it down this second goal of the contest fourth
point of the night head coach David Quinn always
giving your team a chance to think he got got
a way to make it back in but na McKinnon with
his fourth point that was right before the black
offs that puck is loose now Jack Johnson with a
little shimmy move away from leank sends it across
shot save by Blackwood he's still making the push
you're down six to2 out of the final 7 Seconds
here at ball Arena lifted by MC Derman up to
the point not out real Challenge and that will do
it another Sound Crowd here in the mile high city